[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily the police
officer that was shot and injured in a
botched raid
sues brianna taylor's boyfriend and
another department releases dash cam
footage
of an officer-involved shooting as a
surviving victim
files a lawsuit also a podcaster scores
a jailhouse interview with the admitted
con man behind firefast
it is so satisfying to finally see
somebody
who lies through their teeth and lies to
their investors and cheats and steals
finally go to prison how's the fraudster
paying off his millions in damages
law and crime daily covers court cases
from coast to coast
and welcome everybody i'm erin keller
along with brian buckmeyer and terry
austin one of the police officers
involved with the raid which killed
briana taylor is suing her boyfriend
sergeant jonathan mattingly is suing
kenneth walker for pulling the trigger
when mattingly and other plainclothes
officers attempted to execute a warrant
mattingly's lawsuit says the officers
announced who they were according to
many others
they did not walker has said he feared
the officers were intruders so he
grabbed his gun
and fired striking mattingly the lawsuit
accuses walker of causing mattingly
severe trauma mental anguish and
emotional distress
brianna taylor died in the crossfire
former federal prosecutor gene rossi is
here along with brian terry and i
so brian let's start with you walker's
attorney says walker was
justified in pulling the trigger and
that's the defense
was he justified i mean the grand jury
might have indicted him but at least the
prosecutor on the case decided that
there could not go forward because of
the justification
i think if you're taking that 911 call
from kenneth walker
that's really good evidence that he
believed that someone was breaking in
and he had the ability to defend himself
under the castle doctrine so terry
kentucky has what's known as a
firefighters rule which the courts have
said applies
to all first responders not just
firefighters generally
it prevents lawsuits such as this one
from even going forward
but there are many many exceptions and
they're very state specific
do you think the exceptions would allow
mattingly to win
in this case or does it shut down the
case i don't think that mattingly would
win
with the use of any of these exceptions
so the firefighters rule
is a common law rule and what it says is
that when there's a fireman or someone
like a first responder
they're required to actually assume the
risk of their employment
because they're serving the public and
it's a defense that the
occupant of the residents can use and
the only type of exceptions that we
could say here like in kentucky
is if the owner had an obligation to say
well you know
there is a you know uh firearm in here
or
something to that effect that there's
going to blow up and explosives in the
house
there was nothing like that and as a
matter of fact walker had the right to
defend his premises here
so i don't think any of the exceptions
would apply gene rossi your thoughts on
this case it's a bizarre case it's rare
well here's my thoughts on the whole uh
situation
they had a no knock warrant and and
i gotta tell you this i i disagree
respectfully with terry i
i think there may be some justification
arguably as a defense attorney for any
police officer
to say that listen this situation was
explosive from
the moment they entered that apartment
and all heck broke loose
and as a defense attorney i could see an
argument that they had could
be protected by the law and receive
immunity brian do you agree or disagree
so i actually don't think the
firefighter exception will apply here
it's typically used when a third party
calls 9-1-1 for example if
i call 9-1-1 because gene rossi is
beating up aaron keller and the police
come there
i'm not liable but it doesn't really
necessarily help
if gene rossi decides to swing and punch
a cop so i don't think that applies i
think he goes straight to the
allegations here
this rule is very specific based on
which state it's applied in and there's
a lot of wiggle room so look this is an
interesting case
another one for us to watch let's move
on now the us department of justice has
reportedly dropped
its investigation into the cleveland
police shooting of 12-year-old tamir
rice
a 911 caller said rice was carrying a
pellet gun
which looked fake but dispatch never
relayed that information
officer timothy lohmann shot rice almost
immediately after showing up
a local grand jury declined to indict
anyone involved
the new york times reports that
prosecutors asked a federal grand jury
to gather evidence
justice department supervisors
reportedly left that request
to languish for two years before
ultimately
shutting down the inquiry so gene rossi
back to you you're a former federal
prosecutor is this how the doj
operates is this how the doj is supposed
to operate
let me tell you this what the way they
handled mr
tamir rice's case is an absolute
tragedy what happened is they got this
case they opened it up
and it was put in a circular file in a
figurative sense
they did nothing for two and a half
years
i spoke with a former colleague from the
department of justice
who did criminal civil rights cases
title 18
242. i was talking with him yesterday
he's now
in another occupation and he breaks his
heart
that the civil rights division is
nothing but
form over substance and what also breaks
my heart
and makes me very angry actually is they
didn't even do any
wholesome grand jury work zero
nada nothing and what they did is they
handled it politically
and they now are deciding not to go
forward they didn't want to bring this
case because it would offend the police
union
that's pretty harsh gene so bottom line
is you are the doj
should have dug into this and and really
looked at it and basically done its job
gene oh oh absolutely
listen i don't care if their decision
is to go forward or not to go forward we
can debate that
but they didn't even gather the evidence
they didn't allow the victim to speak
that's what really bothers me this young
man this young boy was killed
abbott abaniccio and there should have
been an
investigation to determine if
title 18 section 242 was violated
under color of law and that's what
breaks my heart
they didn't even call witnesses
they didn't even call witnesses gene
rossi appreciate your insight into the
way the doj works on this case and
certainly many others
and still ahead here on law and crime
daily the disgraced founder of the fire
fest hopes he can talk his way into
paying off millions of dollars in
damages but first dash cam footage
of a police pursuit which ended with
gunfire two were shot
only one survived and now she's telling
her side of the story
[Music]
a woman shot by police in waukegan
illinois is suing the two officers
involved and the city
marcellus cenet was shot and killed
after a brief
chase his girlfriend tefera williams was
shot and survived
dash cam video shows an officer chasing
the two here is what happened
mlk passing south
they're going west on helmholtz they
just 50.
in a video statement posted on twitter
by attorney ben crump tafara williams
says her car was
parked when the officer approached
i drove away very slowly because i was
scared to get out of the car
i drove out to mlk and turned on to it
the officer was not following me the
police lights
were not on when i turned onto mlk
it seemed like there was another officer
there waiting for us
there was a crash and i lost control
the officer was shooting at us the car
ended up slamming into a building
i kept screaming i don't have a gun
but he kept shooting he told me to get
out of the car
i had my hands up and i couldn't move
because i had been shot my shoulders had
his hands up
i kept asking him why why
he was shooting the lawsuit claims
officers dante salinas and james keating
used excessive force and
unconstitutional practices so brian
we saw the video we heard the surviving
victims version of the story do you
think the officers were justified
in pulling the trigger or not so let me
be very clear on this
i know that we're in a climate where for
some people it's do what the cops say or
otherwise they can kill you that's
not the law was what she did illegal
driving away from an officer yes was it
dumb
yes but from what i'm seeing in that
video i don't see
where the officer is claiming that this
vehicle is being used as a weapon
against them
that would allow them under the law or
any reasonable belief
that you can shoot at a car in that
manner and that is why it's excessive
so terry same question for you we're
watching the video now basically what
happens is the car goes off the road
right there
almost hits what looks like a phone pole
or something and then it
it reverses in speed very quickly and
the officer is saying it almost hit
him so brian doesn't think that that's
even reasonable we don't have body
camera though
we just have the dash cam and it doesn't
show everything
yeah but you know what i agree with
brian here i think
the use of excessive forces only if they
think their lives are being threatened
here
and here there was no evidence even in
the you know recording that we saw
there's
no evidence that the police officers
lives were
at all in you know danger here and so to
be
shooting at the car to be shooting at
both of them and you know
she couldn't even stand up because of
the shots that happened
i think it was excessive and i think
that there were other things they could
have done they could have taken the
license plate number for goodness sakes
and then chased down where they lived at
the time so no
i don't think this was a justifiable
shooting
terry uh certainly some other tactics
could have been used in your opinion
brian thanks for the analysis let's turn
now to a federal fraud case
against billy mcfarland the disgraced
co-founder of the so-called fire
festival
the plan was to pull together models
celebrities and social media influencers
on an island in the bahamas
and to charge people up to a hundred
thousand dollars each
to attend an exclusive party there the
festival was a well-documented disaster
and is now the subject of a docu-series
on both netflix and hulu mcfarland is
suddenly speaking from his prison cell
with podcaster jordan harbinger
and about rather the six the six
year sentence he received in federal
court for fraud i spoke with harbinger
recently about that interview who cares
what this guy has to say he owes 23
million dollars
everyone complained about this festival
that he threw why is what he has to say
important well i think it's less about
what he has to say being
important and more about what he has to
say being kind of the only way he's
going to make restitution to any of the
victims
that he has under his wake i mean right
now he's serving a six year sentence
uh he's telling us that he's learned his
lessons in solitary confinement and in
prison but
candidly look 23 26 million dollars in
restitution
that's a lot of money for anybody
especially somebody who's behind bars so
i think it's it's more fair to the
victims to allow this to be monetized
he's not taking any of the money
not that you'll find me defending him
what was your conversation like with him
what did he have to say
well the the beginning of the
conversation that didn't make it into
the
episode of the jordan harbinger show
what this little cut that we made was a
a little bit of a stylistic choice
because the first call that we had
uh well first of all each of these
conversations were 10-minute bits
or 12-minute bits from prison because
he's got a 15-minute phone limit and by
the time you connect that's all you have
so the conversation is really stunted in
the first call or two
he simply recited a prepared statement
for the show and you know as a
journalist that's not really what we're
looking for
you know this well we're not looking to
hear what somebody spent
three weeks drafting or memorizing so
once we got through all of that
we were able to have a real conversation
and i'll leave it up to the listener
whether or not he's truthfully contrite
it is tough to see somebody
who's that young go and be locked up
behind bars
on the other hand it's also hard to
convince
me especially just being around this
quite a bit
that somebody goes behind bars for a
couple of years and is immediately
changed immediately realizes everything
they've done
was wrong and didn't realize it
beforehand and is now somehow a changed
man i remain skeptical
after the break that conversation
continues including whether podcaster
jordan harbinger
thinks convicted fraudster billy
mcfarland is continuing his con
from prison
[Music]
[Music]
we're back now with more of my
discussion with podcaster jordan
harbinger who recently scored an
exclusive interview with admitted frauds
for billy mcfarlane
mcfarland's interview with harbinger is
being licensed and some of the money
will go to compensate the victims
i asked harbinger about the effects the
interview has had
do you suspect he's continuing a con
well right now i don't think it can be
much of a con there's not a whole lot of
con
to be had all he can really do is try to
monetize this experience and this story
and again he doesn't get to keep any of
the money what
one might argue that he gets to remain
relevant in the zeitgeist or in pop
culture
and that could later be monetized
whether that's a con or not
it's hard to say in my opinion it could
even be a continuation of
the previous attempts to get attention
and marketing but he's still got a long
way to go in prison i mean there's a
general legal premise that you can't
profit from your crime you can't go
commit a murder and then write a
bestseller about the murder and then go
sell it
and then make yourself a million dollars
even if you're locked up behind bars
so this is a bit interesting because
you're saying the money
is going to go to help pay off the debts
but then the way he's going about it i
think is what's raising the eyebrows
agree 100 i tried to not let him get
away with that
on the jordan harbinger show i asked him
things that were
shameful and embarrassing deliberately
because i don't want it to be
the look what i did aren't i so smart
type of episode i want it to be like
look what i did
this is wrong and i'm being punished for
it and i wanted to highlight that
instead of the clever thinking that went
into firefest in the first place to be
clear i have no
financial connection to him or this
project in
any way at all i got an exclusive
interview with him for the jordan
harbinger show but i also
licensed those clips to be used in a
production called dumpster fire from
notorious studios and dumpster fire
is a production from a la based
production company
uh again called notorious they created a
fire fest
podcast they have not paid him that is
monetize and i believe this is monetized
through
advertising so he will never receive any
funds directly at all the funds will
stay within the production company
notorious
and then his share will be given to uh
the
the state to disburse to the victims it
will i have
no dollars in this whatsoever all i did
was
take the clips from my show uh that i
did as a journalist
and then allow those to be licensed for
this production for
no fee whatsoever it's an important
story because i want it to serve as a
warning sign that you can't just fake it
till you make it there's a real common
trope that goes around among
entrepreneurs
you can just tweak this you could just
fudge that and then all's well that ends
well and the ends justify the means
and frankly i think that billy mcfarland
is a warning sign a
a he's quite the canary of the coal mine
if you will
of hey this doesn't always work out and
this is dangerous territory to tread and
you might be the next person on the
chopping block
and so to come the case of a pro player
accused of using a baseball bat to
commit triple murder
the defense agrees with the facts but
asks police why they used a canine
during the arrest
that cases after the break
[Music]
a former pro baseball player is on trial
after authorities say he used a bat to
beat
three people to death brandon willie
martin faces three counts of
first-degree murder for the deaths of
his father his uncle
and a security system installer
prosecutors believe martin
lost his baseball contract and killed
out of anger the defense says martin
suffers from
mental illness police say martin still
secured the security
system man's wallet and vehicle and then
led them on a high-speed chase
on cross the defense asked the arresting
officer why a canine was used when
martin was already on the ground
as the officer is yelling show us your
hands show us your hands and as the dog
is barking
what is the person lying on disguise
doing
nothing no movement no movement in fact
i think you said earlier you weren't
even sure if he was conscious correct
correct
but before the dog gets there he doesn't
no sir when the law gets there and you
said pokes around or sniffs around with
his snout
does the person move no i i just
remember seeing the dog
kind of latched on to his like growing
area
okay where his penis would be crap after
that he
slammed a dog on the ground yeah the dog
yelped
or whatever you want to call it
squealing which point
we took him to the ground and he landed
on his hands
martin was arrested and taken to the
hospital five days later he was booked
into jail and agreed to speak with the
lead investigator for an interview
his demeanor was he was eager that i was
there he wanted to speak with me
and the only thing that
i would say that the conversation was
fluid and
he seemed a little bit tired but other
than that he seemed responsive
did he tell you that um he was taking
some pain medication
for injury to his shoulder yes
you're shown to a room that has
plexiglass down the middle of the room
and seats on either side of the
plexiglass and
plexiglas in front communication is
through the
telephonic communication device that
they have there yes
and it can be frustrating talking
through that telephone
extremely frustrating uncrossed the
defense emphasized that the defendant
was cooperative during the interview and
even remorseful
earlier in the interview we heard you
made reference to
brandon getting upset and crying do you
remember that
yes i believe the topic was his father
is that right
that is right and when you were talking
about him crying would you describe
what you saw on mr brent on mr martin's
face what did you see
i saw tears okay and it sounded like
there was at least a pause of a few
maybe 30 seconds where it's
if i had to guess it appears brynn was
basically collecting
collecting himself so he could continue
to answer questions yes he was gathering
his composure
did you notice any injuries to brandon's
person when you spoke with him on the
22nd yes his face
he had bruising and scabbing to his face
on his cheek area
okay terry so is the k-9 situation
relevant or is the defense spinning its
wheels asking about that
i think it's relevant aaron you know he
has the murder charges and clearly those
are important but when a jury hears
about
someone abusing a dog i think that it's
going to influence them
so brian why is the defense asking about
remorse when the insanity defense
basically requires a finding the
defendant didn't know right from wrong
so this is the beginning of the trial
remember this is just asking the
question of guilt or innocence the
second part will be
to decide whether or not there's some
sort of insanity or defense or mental
defect
this could be the defense simply pulling
up straws to see what might fall here
or this could be something that comes
all together it's amazing we just got to
wait and see
yeah i mean sometimes we don't see the
exact light at the end of the tunnel
until the very end brian and terry
appreciate the time here on law and
crime daily and thank you for joining us
watching along at home
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america right here
on law and crime daily
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
we break down the case of a serial
killer another day of drama between both
sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law and crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this
is law and crime
[Music]
you